okay I've got the request for a new game
started well got some time now so a
couple of firm of subscribers to the
channel and kept asking me what what
game I'm playing it's a exam and a
role-playing game the team started the
Elder Scrolls 5 skyrim and it's a
terribly addictive game it's very hard
for me to stop to stop playing it and
but I think I'm close to having seen
most of the game so we used the time now
spend on this okay we got some strange
French mix he played with them with F
form naudia form yeah just I was just
playing the French to to vary a bit here
and I must admit that I don't know don't
know this very well may be h 5
yeah my Bishop g2 wasn't too great
because of each form
yeah I'm asking myself or what about a
move like tea for here is an idea even
other addict to to prevent him to play
d4 even okay let's let's try this
okay well of course i'd like to print to
get the bishop on the long diagonal it's
so only I don't know it's looking a bit
a bit slow and maybe it's um it's better
to to take with through the G porn I
don't like the idea of playing on the
bishop to be seven and then then you
would take it takes and then you play c6
or something ok let's get this Bishop to
be seven I'm not sure maybe the shanty
the center has a bit shaky here but hard
for me to believe that this should be it
should be good for white with this great
bishop on b7 well he wants to go to e4
obviously but if I take on c3 isn't d3
just hanging ok show me
yet I can just take this pawn his gut
awful position pieces so it's not so not
obvious on what compensation he could
have made me okay be sure to g to okc 60
some hanging with Jackson let's just
protect this okay well this looks just
like a complete disaster for what I
could even take C 3 it's not so much
about the porn but the queen is very
irritating deep inside scamp it's not
some
well I don't see anything special can
you keep it a ticket with 91 I'll always
have more squares a fire for something
I could take it once more why didn't see
this one coming hopefully am it's not
lost Wow ok my queen doesn't have so
many squares maybe I should just have
retreated this piece rook be one maybe I
don't have a square ah well this is
completely ridiculous oh I didn't he
didn't go for this I could go to a for
now but still I would would have this
stupid remove I'm down to one minute was
crazy game time warning now we saw it
yeah great ok I didn't have her square
for the Queen so I need to need to go
for this
I have what a stupid game I should just
have gone to dis heaven and it's it's
just winning with no hassle at all
and I'm down two down two very little
time I guess in a blitz can this is not
even that clear because whites position
is so utterly an ammonia stat that it's
maybe even playable
I keep I keep forgetting about moves
rook a three can I think rook a three
just trapped I would have trapped my
queen again now I've got e6 at the
square okay this is a most likely a
really terrible game okay now
threatening t2 and can I go there
d 2 was just hand was just hanging check
check I can take it now now I'm three
pawns up surprisingly okay I want to get
to his Kings maybe just terrible move
but check check check
check check check check ah yeah
checkmate next smooth white resume okay
I quite a silly game to finish it to
finish this the session yeah it was just
just tell I should just drop this back
to 27 and let's just check quickly yeah
we went to yeah the computer is already
on plus three the queen is trapped yeah
terrible i justjust I just saw this
happen and it's it's basically over it's
not just a pawn it's all positions this
complete position collapses if the porn
on d3 is gone okay well just grab one
pawn and then humbly retreat it's better
to be greedy obviously yeah thanks for
for watching and see you I guess maybe
tomorrow or day after tomorrow with with
new games